hello and welcome to this video mata
leão with white let's see what is coming
up with kind of happy with the English
opening at the moment I'm getting in
some fresher positions that i have not
yet played that much over the years i'm
not going to not intending to play a tag
every game in the future but i think
it's some room for the moment quite
interesting okay so this was probably
not such a great mood for 92 maybe I
should have played shows deform yeah
okay taking that was d3n that wasn't all
that that much of a problem
yeah so fresh position here that I have
no idea about so I want to go D for next
which he prevented but may be here right
mmm takes it he takes and then d3 next
that should be pretty okay right
shouldn't forget the development
situation so would be 3d for I think I
rather take I want it as open as
possible sorry in this position yeah
maybe just be should be too interesting
situation here I can take make sure i
want this is also interesting putting
the night over to deform may be asking
what he is going to do hear something
like this should be 6 9 p-5 494 should
be interesting night c7 also was a
threat so night before now or there are
also alternatives here even Bishop to e5
is kind of interesting
as for me Luke see ADA but still it has
interesting let's try it
not sure maybe he can play rook c8 or
something give away a 7 it is a little
bit annoying this move and it was my
suspicions it is probably able to do
that okay we take since 96 yeah 96 on
let's me the bishop pair if I take a 7mm
that's Queen to c5 so okay give me the
bishops
yeah so I think I'll do here d 4 is a
fantastic square if i can get it okay
wants to go look see 8 so let's do this
prevent you create taking on d3 i'm not
fearing that much and Roxy one is my
next move ok i will see one next
yeah that's a nice ending check ok so I
can win the pawn here I think I'll do
that I can take a three eyes still wins
upon
it's the grave FOIA but I can take
another poem that's a little bit a
little bit much resign shows off
generosity ok I'm reasonably happy with
the game at least my impression during
the actual play yeah this is an
interesting movie for but I have kind of
forgotten I think d3 is what I should do
yeah I should play that immediately I ok
this he I think taking us not so great
as d3s a bit a bit of a nuisance I mean
he can take but that looks very strange
I think here I probably have a good
position it looks very weird I can
probably come here and like the beep
horn that's good compensation ok and now
93 I'm not sure about this is a very
time-consuming medulla win 1 2 3 and so
on this is a like I think this should be
nice 25 took it and d3 yeah yeah yeah I
think white is better i'm in the
computer this house is this is equal but
i'm not i'm not convinced I don't know
why this should be equal I'm attacking a
center here and I have the better
development also this is not looking so
great maybe Bishop here
yeah in the computers still says equal
if it wasn't for that I would just say
why does having a great game here I have
night coming to deform yeah it looks
good it looks good we have seven okay
well then engine now with a very very
nice move Bishop h3 this makes 94 very
very substantial threat it's a cool idea
no no it was outside of my ability it is
indeed very nice yeah it's a nice
position White's pieces are just making
a very nice impression and I'm taking
this nay I didn't see that I saw this
move which are also like he went rook c8
my thread is 97 so rook c8 and took it
and I'll just grab the bishops and this
is just a bit better phone for white not
much fun Kim and here it gets it gets
serious yes to deal with this pressure
and what is the D boots that puts the
deal this one lakh in the computer
replies something that I don't really
see a human player coming up with it
rookie one trapping it pretty cute so
that doesn't work that also doesn't
now okay that suits really strong but ok
this is human move also shouldn't be all
that bad and now I was just happy with
the Queen trade this is something that
you certainly can I can debate but man
is ending is just just great for white
the bishop here in a somewhat open
position and no play whatsoever for
blackjack yeah and now he blundered you
form he has to take I guess maybe not
you for yeah we white a white cat num
torture black here forever with the two
bishops and the better structure it's a
win hard to say but this is probably
just too much and you give me a second
poll um yes to go b6 first 83 there
should be six beautiful this kind of
thing yeah white has excellent winning
chances is it a win not totally sure
yeah okay I like the gamer I think it
was a reasonably well played thanks for
watching